after?
Guiness World RecordAccording to Guinness
World Records, the de-facto authority on world
record breaking, this is one of the most common
questions they’re asked alongside “What
record is broken the most often?” (the heaviest
object lifted with glue according to them)
and “Who holds the most Guinness World Records
record titles?”
(Ashrita Furman with 125 records at last count).
Since we’ve also gotten this question a
few times from readers over the years, we
figured it’s high time we looked into the
answer.
In regards to records involving comically
giant food, as of 2011, Guinness has a policy
in place that all giant food or records involving
large amounts of food, such as most pizzas
made in 24 hours (7,539 by a team of Domino’s
employees in Queensland in 2012), must be
either donated, consumed or sold for consumption
for the record to be recognised as official.
This stipulation was put in place for a number
of reasons, but was mostly added to prevent
such a large amount of food going to waste,
something Guinness was being criticised for
encouraging.
Guinness allows those attempting records to
choose between selling or donating giant food
in acknowledgement of the fact that such records
often require a considerable amount of money
and the option of selling it allows some of
that money to be recouped.
A second, and perhaps less obvious, reason
for this particular stipulation is that it
means the food produced, whatever it may be,
has to be edible, making it much harder to
break some of these giant food records.
For example, when a company called Juicys
Outlaw Grill attempted to create a record
breaking 770 pound burger in 2011, their initial
attempt failed when they were unable to cook
the 600 pound beef patty they’d made all
the way through– meaning the entire burger
could not be eaten and thus, they were unable
to fulfill all of Guinness’ stipulations
to a satisfactory degree, even though they
technically did make a 770 pound burger.
The company did eventually succeed at breaking
the world record and now holds the record
for selling the largest commercially available
hamburger in the world.
The price?
A mere $5000 dollars for over one million
calories of burgery goodness, give or take
depending on the fat content.
And if you’re curious, a typical beef cow
yields about 450 pounds or about 200 kg of
usable meat.
So this world record attempt was essentially
about one and a third cows worth of meat or
about 6000 McDonald’s hamburgers.
A further stipulation of creating giant food
for a world record attempt is that it must
generally resemble the original foodstuff
it is based on.
For example, a stipulation of creating a giant
popsicle is that the final product must be
able to stand upright like a regular popsicle
without falling apart.
This is a rule the company Snapple were unable
to abide by when they attempted to create
a record breaking 35,000 pound stick of frozen
goo in 2005 and inexplicably tried to erect
it in the middle of New York in June…
Despite careful preparation before hand and
keeping the giant popsicle frozen during transport
to its final destination, the kiwi-strawberry
popsicle melted before it could be propped
up, resulting in thousands of litres of pink,
sugary liquid shutting off several lanes of
traffic while a bemused fire crew used hoses
to wash it down into the sewers.
Presumably the rats and other such creatures
appreciated Snapple’s efforts, even if they
didn’t get the world record.
Perhaps next time they should think about
doing it in December.
Of course, because Guinness isn’t always
invited along to giant food cook-offs, there’s
nothing to really stop companies or individuals
that create giant food from throwing it away
after the attempt is complete; it’s just
that if they do, the most recognisable world
record recording entity won’t give them
a plaque acknowledging their achievement.
This means the group in question won’t get
near the publicity, which is generally the
point of these sorts of things.
On top of that, if they aren’t making the
food item edible, they just completely wasted
their money on the raw ingredients for no
good reason.
Needless to say, officials from Guinness are
often invited to such events and, even when
not, the food item is generally meant to be
eaten after.